hello and welcome to this episode of the
apogee accelerator Series in this video
we'll be demonstrating how to implement
the client credentials Grant type using
apogee's built-in oauth policies let's
get started
let's do a quick overview of the client
credential roles to help illustrate
where apogee fits in
we'll start with the client app
which is an API consumer that needs
access to protected resources
typically with this flow the client runs
on a server rather than locally on a
user's laptop or device
in our sample apogee is the oauth
authorization server its role is to
generate access tokens validate access
tokens and pass authorized requests for
protected resources to the resource
server
the resource server is a back-end
service that stores the protected data
that our client app needs permission to
access in our sample apigee is also the
resource server
now let's walk through the flow
The Client app requests an access token
to receive an access token the client
posts an API call to apogee with the
values for client ID and client secret
obtained from a registered developer app
apogee then validates these credentials
if the credentials are valid apogee
returns an access token to the client if
not an error is returned
now with a valid access token the client
can make calls to the protected API in
this diagram requests are made to apogee
and apigee is responsible for validating
the access token before passing the API
call along to the Target resource server
which responds with the requested
resource now let's walk through how to
deploy and test this sample
in order to deploy and test this sample
you'll need an apigee instance
provisioned with access configured for
external traffic
as a user you'll need permissions to
deploy API proxies create API products
and register developers and applications
this can be granted through the apogee
org admin role or the API and developer
admin roles
to deploy the sample you'll also need
the command line tool shown here
if you're using Google Cloud shell these
are already installed
we've included a Google Cloud shell
tutorial which you can simply click to
quickly get started
now that you're in the cloud Channel
environment you can follow the
step-by-step instructions on the right
hand side
first make sure you're logged in with
the right account
then change to the directory for this
sample
to deploy the sample first open the nvsh
file and set the configuration to
reference your apogee project
environment and external hostname
when you've finished Source the m.sh
file on the command line
next run the included script to deploy
the sample to your apogee instance and
wait for it to complete it could take a
few minutes
once the deployment is complete take a
minute to read some of the text output
you should see the automated tests have
passed and you'll also be presented with
the deployed proxy URL and the client ID
and secret from the sample developer app
you'll then see some example curl
commands which you can use to test the
sample for yourself
first obtain a short-lived access token
using the token endpoint
then scroll back up to copy the second
curl command which allows you to access
the protected resource
don't forget to add a token you just
received and end the command with
closing quotation marks
you'll now see a message returned from
the protected API
when you're done with the sample you can
provide us with feedback if you like and
then you can use the cleanup script to
delete the resources that were deployed
to your apogee organization
I hope you found this video useful you
can subscribe to our channel to see more
videos in the apogee accelerator series
if you have questions please visit the
apogee community and thanks for watching